[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es hacia el magazine quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
se mantiene la atención en la Península
coreana tras los recientes lanzamientos
de misiles por parte de Corea del Norte
que despiertan alarma no solo en los
países de la región como Corea del Sur y
Japón sino en la comunidad internacional
en esta edición de Así es Asia
analizamos los alcances de esos
lanzamientos y que se puede esperar en
el futuro inmediato el gobierno de India
empieza a ver los beneficios de su
campaña de turismo hacia cachemira en
los primeros seis meses de este año
cerca de dos millones de viajeros indios
visitaron este territorio y disputa con
Pakistán una cifra que cuadruplica la
reportadas en 2019
y visitaremos un suburbio de yokohama en
el sur de Japón donde casi la mitad de
los residentes son jubilados en una
comunidad modelo porque evitan la
soledad manteniéndose ocupados en su día
a día
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en Corea del Norte
que en las últimas semanas ha lanzado
varios misiles de corto mediano y largo
alcance en aguas de la costa oriental de
la Península de Corea y los cuales han
despertado alarma tanto en países de la
región como en la comunidad
internacional
esto ha llevado a que Estados Unidos y
Corea del Sur realizan ejercicios
militares en la zona y que Japón haya
respondido de una manera enérgica a lo
que ha llamado una amenaza real e
incluso ha sugerido que el régimen de
Kim jong-un ha podido desarrollar ojivas
nucleares en miniatura para ser
transportadas por misiles balísticos de
mediano alcance en un ataque para
analizar los alcances de estos
lanzamientos previamente hablamos con
constanza jorquera analista política
internacional e investigadora asociada
del centro de estudios coreanos de la
Universidad de Santiago de Chile que nos
explicó el contexto en el que Corea del
Norte realiza estas acciones
Bueno estamos una situación bastante
inestable donde muchas voces hablan de
dinámicas de una nueva guerra fría sobre
todo porque Contamos con antecedentes
previos que hay que tener en
consideración no solamente lo que está
sucediendo en Ucrania con Rusia en este
en este momento desde la guerra cierto y
la invasión que se inicia a principios
de año sino porque esto también es parte
de un cuestionamiento de Putin al orden
liberal occidental y tiene consecuencias
también para todo el mundo considerando
que Corea del Norte está siempre
constantemente siendo una amenaza para
la seguridad internacional no solamente
en Asia Pacífico donde confluyen las
mayores potencias del mundo incluyendo
Estados Unidos entendiendo la comuna
potencia Global en el Pacífico sino que
también en los vaivenes y las dinámicas
de las relaciones internacionales
recientemente el líder de Corea del
Norte Kim Jong un señaló que sus fuerzas
nucleares listas para abro comillas una
guerra real consultamos a constanza
jorquera Hasta qué punto esa nación
tiene la capacidad de desarrollar un
arma nuclear
Estos son especulaciones se dice que sí
tendría estas capacidades porque Kim una
endureció la doctrina nuclear del país
una vez que llega al poder y sobre todo
acelerándonos en los últimos años y ha
dicho que nunca va a renunciar a las
armas nucleares mientras Estados Unidos
y Corea del Sur sigan realizando
ejercicios conjuntos
también aquí hay que tener en cuenta que
el programa nuclear de Corea del Norte
si bien a veces se podría decir o cuando
hubo mayor acercamiento con Estados
Unidos y con Corea del Sur que eso se
había detenido es parte de letos de
Corea del Norte entonces la única forma
de medir el alcance y las pruebas que
hacen es a través de la inteligencia de
Corea del Sur y Estados Unidos en ese
sentido Yo diría que Corea del Norte sí
tiene la capacidad pero de allí que sea
efectivo y que efectivamente pudiera
llevar adelante un conflicto o una
estrategia de este tipo
pienso que sería irresponsable decir que
eso sí ocurriría frente a todo este
escenario Cuál es el riesgo que corre
Asia con estos misiles esto nos dijo la
analista al respecto
pienso que hacía Pacífico ya se Oriental
en particular es una subregión que nunca
ha salido de la dinámica de conflicto
latente de la Guerra Fría en ese sentido
se diferencia de otras regiones que
también mantiene dinámicas de conflicto
y de inestabilidad pero de formas
distintas bien en ese sentido Corea del
Norte siempre ha sido un agente
desestabilizador de la región Y eso está
constantemente presente en la toma de
decisiones de los actores que lo rodean
pienso que
me atrevería a decir que estamos
volviendo a
el estado tan peligroso y amenazante Y
de escalada qué ocurrió en 2017
agradecemos a constanza porque era por
su análisis ahora vamos a India porque
el gobierno está viendo los beneficios
de una campaña de turismo de Gran
presupuesto que puso en marcha el año
pasado para atraer a personas a
cachemira más de 1,6 millones de
viajeros indios visitaron ese territorio
en disputa con Pakistán en los primeros
seis meses de este año atraídos por el
impresionante paisaje del Himalaya y los
remoto santuarios hindúes los turistas
han acudido en masa a cachemira sin
dejarse intimidar por la fuerte
presencia militar
es el nuevo destino vacacional más
popular de India atraídos por el
impresionante paisaje del Himalaya y los
remotos santuarios hindúes los indios
han acudido en masa a calle Mira este
año sin dejar sin intimidar por la larga
insurgencia del territorio en disputa o
la fuerte presencia militar
me sentí un poco inseguro porque había
oído hablar mucho de cachemira y de la
violencia básicamente
pero a través de la televisión me enteré
de que el gobierno se está ocupando de
la región
eso se debe a un esfuerzo específico del
gobierno de India para traer a los
turistas nacionales de vuelta cachemira
el turismo es una parte integral de la
economía local pero cayó en picado
después del 5 de agosto de 2019 cuando
el gobierno indio revocó la autonomía
limitada garantizada constitucionalmente
al territorio imponiendo restricciones a
la población y cerrando internet durante
meses sin sin embargo el año pasado las
autoridades volvieron a promocionar la
región entre los indios ya que el
presupuesto de turismo del gobierno
local Se cuadruplicó con un resultado
del cuádruple de visitantes a calle mira
en los primeros seis meses de este año
en comparación con 2019
Cuantos más turistas más puestos de
trabajo no hemos visto tantos turistas
aquí en más de dos años las
restricciones de Kobe 19 También
causaron muchas pérdidas pero este año
nos ha ido bien
sin embargo otros habitantes de la zona
que no quisieron hablar no ven con
buenos ojos la afluencia de turistas
indios algo que consideran un intento de
Nueva Delhi por reforzar a su control
sobre la región la larga insurgencia se
paratista en el valle de mayoría
musulmana se ha cobrado la vida de miles
de personas en las últimas tres décadas
les contento con el gobierno indio
prevalece en el territorio y los
enfrentamientos
los separatistas y las tropas siguen
estallando casi todas las semanas así es
Asia y se lo contamos en Francia 24
Estos son otros hechos destacados que
marcan la agenda del continente
este 16 de octubre inicia el vigésimo
congreso del partido comunista chino en
el que se prevé Queen sea elegido para
un tercer mandato como secretario
general y por lo tanto presidente de
China todo esto se da en medio del
aumento de casos y de pruebas de
detección de Kobe 19 en la capital
Beijing y en las ciudades de Shanghai y
otras 36 urbes situaciones que han
tenido un impacto Severo en la economía
de ayuda de los cierres totales o
parciales
en llamar un tribunal de la junta
militar ordenó a seis años de cárcel a
la depuesta líder onzan Sushi por
corrupción elevando hacía 26 años el
total de la pena de prisión que deberá
cumplir recordemos que la novel de paz
de 77 años se encuentra detenida desde
el golpe de estado de 2021 que derrocó
su gobierno
es también acusada de violar normas
contra la pandemia del 19 y la ley de
secretos oficiales así como de fraude
electoral
en Tailandia del gobierno anunció un
endurecimiento en la ley para la compra
y adquisición de armas luego del tiroteo
ocurrido Hace unos días en el que un ex
policía con una pistola y un cuchillo
asesinó a 37 personas incluidas 24 niños
en una guardería las nuevas medidas
incluyen evaluaciones psicológicas para
los compradores y para aquellos que ya
poseen armas e incluso para los
funcionarios gubernamentales
cambiamos de tema y nos dirigimos a
Japón casi la mitad de los residentes
del suburbio de wakabadi en el sureste
del país son jubilados Pero eso no les
ha impedido seguir muy activos en su
vida diaria buscando emplearse o
realizando diferentes actividades
aprovechan sus últimos años tomando el
control de su comunidad Esta es la
historia
personas de 80 años jugando al Golf es
algo común en wakabaday en los suburbios
de yokohama
este hombre de 89 años viene a jugar
tres veces por semana
es mejor que estar sentado frente a la
televisión hago algo de ejercicio es
bueno para mis piernas y camino más de 3
kilómetros Cuando vengo aquí
la mitad de los residentes de guacamada
y están jubilados juntos se aseguran de
tener todos los servicios que necesitan
para disfrutar al máximo de su vida
las actividades sociales y las comidas
comunitarias ayudan a prevenir la
soledad por ejemplo esta mujer vino a
vivir o acabada y tras la muerte de su
esposo
Yo vivía en el segundo piso y no había
ascensor pero aquí todos los edificios
lo tienen es genial y hecho amigos como
ella
los residentes mayores del barrio
contribuyen a la vida local de formas
inesperadas incluso gestionan esta
guardería donde los Padres pueden venir
con sus hijos por menos de un dólar al
día de este lanzando es más fácil
divertido estar aquí con los jubilados
que cuidar a mis dos hijos en casa estoy
sola con ellos allí Así que las cosas
pueden volverse un poco locas
a esta mujer de 69 años se le ha pagado
una pequeña suma por ayudar en la
guardería Durante los últimos 8 años
ella dice que todo esto la mantiene
activa activa
es algo que quiero hacer no podía
trabajar cuando estaba criando a mis
hijos pero eso se acabó me preguntaron
si quería ayudar y he estado aquí desde
el principio Me encantan los niños Así
que gastar el tiempo con ellos me da
energía positiva
Durante los últimos cinco años los
investigadores han estudiado a las
personas independientes de huacabaday y
por una buena razón los mayores de 65
años y ha constituyen el 36% de la
población japonesa y para el cierre les
dejo algunos datos en Asia existen
varias y diferentes religiones cultos y
creencias practicadas por su población
entre las que se destacan el islam
hinduismo budismo confucianismo
cristianismo catolicismo entre otras
haciendo de este continente el más
diverso del mundo en muchos aspectos
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es hacia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]